my life today went out like my wife was
putting a new car seat in the car was
the one that's in there now no no it's
not comfortable no of that two-year-old
she brought up she's got some specific
tastes I thought I'm gonna say to each
rolls how sometimes how detached I feel
from my body my wife he's active she is
of the earth she knows how to be she
knows how to do things thank [ __ ]
it was unlike some gaseous little poet
just floating around commentating you
know where she picks up that car seat
she gets it now if you leave me to put a
car seat in top the top tether strap
into the buckle loop
I looked it but that's not how you're
wired you know she grounds you but you
can you know show the vision yeah
exactly like you need both of that right
yeah we know you bet you met Julie you
can see there's a similar kind of like
yin-yang dynamic yeah what is it with
you guys
I mean I'm much more grounded in
practical and rational and she you know
she's you know an ethereal being you
know and she allows me to expand my my
not only my perspective but my sense of
what's possible she'll say why don't you
look at it from this perspective and
something I never would have thought of
and a sense of belief like a support and
a belief in a different reality that she
held for us we've been together for a
very long time yeah
we've gone through a lot and when we met
we were living completely different
lives but she held this vision that I
could not have seen myself so you and
you and you I think you I would imagine
I'm projecting completely but that you
fulfill that role in your own
relationship yes I'm actually I mean in
the sense of a vision as in imagining
and dreaming new spaces yes but it was
my wife we met when like in iself 11 12
years ago and she knew that we were
meant to be together and I knew I had to
try and set world records for promise
[Laughter]
how did you how did you overcome that
like did you just acquiesce over time or
what was that process like for you the
way actually wasn't the promiscuity
ultimately that was problematic but it
was more difficult codependent
relationship
appropriate partners like in my case
just people that I wasn't like I was
very attracted to this is wonderful
Robert Johnson he's a Jungian analyst
who breaks down myths and uses them as
relationship tools he wrote one called
he one called she one call we and like
her he uses the Arthurian legend of
Kristen and his older to break down this
is a lovely bit of analysis actually but
the chivalric tradition of knights in
that was to that the knight would fight
for the honor of a woman and at least
that these tales are written in mythic
language when we translate them
literally that's why you know when
people talk about Disney theosis staff
it seeps down into every aspect of our
culture and how we think about yes the
male and female is in us in in a fairy
tale not suggesting in the Disney
version I don't know what objectives
they have over there and that crazy
castle but like in their original fairy
stories their female is an aspect of it
with it well as in dreams as in folk
tales the individual the sovereign the
king is the you know the seat within
this self and they're like so in this
Tristan and there's old and Miffy bred
like he breaks down the chivalric
tradition when men or knights would
fight for the honor of the princess or
whatever knowing that they would never
be attained because there are some icon
of the divine and the unattainable we
somehow used that motif if for the
foundation of romantic love and like if
you look at sort of romantic or romantic
poetry romantic films this yearning this
terrible yearning that has no
relationship to practice it has no
relation to live this in the myth of
Tristan and Isolda they're like he then
Tristan the night falls in love with
Zolder who he was meant to go and fetch
from an island for the king and his
older is an ethereal magical creature he
came from an island you have to get
across the water to bring her back and
none of these people are actual females
or males they're mythic archetypes so
like you know and he's in love with her
but he'd not met you can't be with that
magical person but when he meets her
true what's her name his older the white
hands if she's a sister of a kinsman of
his he's fighting you know lay alongside
and she you know he talks about in the
myth that she's in the furnace she's
doing stuff with firewood and that
can't be with her he can't be earth
because him we are looking sometimes for
the other person in our relationship to
be an emblem of the divine and they are
flawed fallible people but sometimes you
know initially with that rush of early
love is so intoxicating isn't it
wonderful when you do when that you
experience that you know when I'm
watching a film or falcata to be 16 18
20 whatever again and to feel that
delirium of all this [ __ ] person they
are God to me they are good on me even
better if they're broken
oh yes and then we can really get in
really destroy ourselves roller coaster
ride well I after a few relationships
like that like after sort of exiting one
I felt like was to Jimmy a mentor said
I'd like Lee goes you can't keep doing
that next time you see the sign pointing
in the direction of their glamorous
amazing relationship maybe don't go that
way
it's so hard though oh yeah I mean it's
so very alluring the flesh is alluring
and like in it that you know that we
don't good we are physical people it's
nothing wrong with her you know unto
Caesar what is Caesar's and all that
there's nothing wrong with the bodies in
the world and but you'd knock down that
door enough time I mean you know you
know what that avails you yeah and when
I reconnected with my wife I felt like
oh my god I've been using totally the
wrong metric was it what do you mean
reconnected you had known her previous
yeah we known each other for 11 years we
went out when I was about in my early
thirties and she was like 20 maybe she
was even nineteen but that sounds well
but anyway like so then I was went off
to pursue the record and then like and
you know when we got back like we went
on sort of one day and on the first day
is that also you and she's like you know
I'm ready to be a parent yeah me too and
that was you know like from then on we
sort of took it's relatively slowly
still but I think that's only four years
ago and we're married and we've got two
children and I'm like I'm at peace I
know like the realness of it the earth
ness of it I'm no longer looking to
externally acquire happiness so to what
do you attribute that shift
the program the program the Billy
because I've known that that could have
happened at any point you know it's no
not for ten years but I just wasn't
ready to see that I wasn't ready to let
go of the belief that no no I've you
know I want to live this kind of life I
want to be this kind of person and it's
odd actually because there is a real
superficiality to that sort of romantic
and expressive and abundant love in that
when those relationships ended I was
quite Mabel for some well okay because
it was something about it there was a
construct it was taking place in my
consciousness primarily this
relationship was very very very deep
very earth and real like this is a
person that I wouldn't want to be
without you know so inside not
surrendered to that before yeah and for
years now yeah yeah it's good it's a
relief it's nice to think that there is
nothing like I do it's nice to have
practices I suppose you know as the
institution of marriage and coupling and
stuff I suppose it works in that it's
beautiful to feel you know that idea of
like there appear I am here that's
seeing I but my little daughter says I
sit in my seat I sit in my seat I'm
looking over there for something else
there isn't some other new magical thing
no other agenda being present and in it
but also with enough awareness and
personal development to understand that
you know you're not looking to this
partner to complete you and that's your
own personal journey that's your
connection with your higher power and
your your you know spiritual interior
self and your relationship to
spirituality in general right that that
can't be solved through relationship
with another human being no no I think
that is the you know crux of of
suffering for a lot of people it's good
to have that it's good for to have some
principles of like you know so next time
I find myself going Laura will you do
this why didn't you do that I won this
like the tail that's that thing that's
never gonna work you're doing again and
every time I sell it to myself as year
but though this time I am actually right
my relationship with other people is an
opportunity to be of service it's not an
opportunity to be served
[Music]